I know your pain, I know you're hurt.
We had an election that was stolen from us,
it was a landslide election,
and everyone knows it especially the other side,
but you have to go home now.
Donald Trump's response to last week's attack on the US Capitol led Twitter
to permanently ban him from its platform,
and Facebook and YouTube closed his accounts
on the grounds that he had used their platforms to incite violence.
Next Apple and Google banned the Twitter competitor, Parler,
from its app stores on the grounds that
the perpetrators of last week's attack used it to coordinate,
and because the service doesn't engage in adequate content moderation.
Then Amazon which owns about a third of the global cloud storage market,
evicted Parler from its cloud hosting service
taking the site down entirely.
These decisions drew a ferocious reaction,
both for and against,
from people of all political stripes.
For better or worse, as Edward Snowden put it after Trump was kicked off Twitter,
this will be remembered as a turning point
in the battle for control over digital speech.
It is stunning to watch now as every war on terror rhetorical tactic
to justify civil liberties erosions is now being invoked in the name of combating Trumpism,"
wrote Glenn Greenwald.
So how should those who value a free and open society
feel about the deplatforming of the commander-in-chief?
The ongoing purge of many of his supporters
and repression of discussion of 2020 election voter fraud claims.
Twitter is a private company and CEO Jack Dorsey's capacity
to evict even the president of the United States,
is something worth valuing.
But what if the network power
of a handful of Silicon Valley giants,
is so great that there's nowhere else to turn?
And are Facebook, Twitter, and Google acting independently
or bending to the will of Congress
at a time when tech has been so deeply politicized?
The takeaway from the great deplatforming of 2021 is that
we need now more than ever an open digital commons
where individuals can maintain ownership of their own identities
and speech is highly resistant to political pressure.
Decentralized networks are vital to protecting open discourse
not only from Twitter, Facebook, and Google
but from Ted Cruz, Joe Biden, Josh Hawley, or Kamala Harris,
which is where the real power lies
to stomp on the free speech rights of American citizens.
It's easy to forget that not long ago,
Twitter's Jack Dorsey and Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg
embraced the concept of a neutral public square.
We do not want to become the arbiters of truth.
The shift from digital commons
to actively curated newsfeed was underway long before the election.
In October of 2020, Facebook deranked and Twitter blocked
the sharing of a New York post story,
claiming that Joe Biden met with an executive
at a Ukrainian gas company where his son held a board seat.
Twitter also blocked the nation's oldest newspaper
from using its account for more than two weeks.
When the New York Times' Kara Swisher,
grilled Parler CEO John Matze about Parler's role in inciting the Capitol breach,
he defended its hands off approach.
If it was organized on your site,
what should happen on your site?
If it was illegally organized
and against the law and what they were doing,
they would've gotten it taken down,
but I don't feel responsible for any of this
and neither should the platform,
considering we're a neutral town square.
The handful of companies that own the dominant share of social media
and the underlying infrastructure of the internet disagree,
and have made it increasingly difficult for Parler to operate,
but the most dangerous threat isn't coming from Silicon Valley.
To get what they want from tech CEOs,
both Republicans and Democrats,
have regularly threatened to strip away
the liability protections provided by section 230
of the Communications and Decency Act,
which is known as the internet's First Amendment.
Through the effect of section 230
a special immunity from liability that nobody else gets.
Congress has given big tech in effect, a subsidy.
That's a pretty foundational law, of the modern network of internet.
Exactly right.
And it should be revoked.
Democrats want to leverage section 230
to force them to weed out misinformation,
which they falsely imagined can be sorted out
by panels of accredited experts
or finely tuned algorithms.
Republicans have threatened to repeal 230
unless platforms commit to viewpoint neutrality
a standard which Stanford technologist,
Daphne Keller, says is impossible to uphold.
I don't even know what being neutral would mean.
Would it mean allowing every single thing
to be uploaded and just showing it in chronological order?
Can you be neutral if you have search features?
Can you be neutral if you allow people to mute things?
I think a truly neutral meaning,
showing everything that is legal,
social media platform would be full of content
that most users don't want to see.
President-elect Biden is making a public push for a new domestic terrorism law
and red flag laws,
which would make it easier for federal agents
to seize firearms based on a user's online posts.
Perhaps Americans way of thinking about free speech,
is not the best way,
wrote Emily Bazelon in the New York Times magazine.
At the very least, we should understand
that it isn't the only way.
And that European speech regulations
have created better conditions for their citizenry
to sort out what's true from what's not
and to make informed decisions
about what they want. their societies to be.
But in the EU, these regulations have created unintended consequences
of flagging content that's disturbing,
yet vital to the public interest.
Such as an archive of Syrian war crimes,
wrongly flagged as terrorist content
under the EU guidelines.
Right now,
we don't have any clear information telling us that,
taking down all of these videos really is making us safer.
In fact, a lot of people,
who are expert researchers on security,
are concerned that this will effectively drive more people
into darker corners of the internet,
into echo chambers where they only ever hear
from people who agree with a violent agenda.
What do you think when people are saying
it's time for civil war,
I'm bringing my guns to Washington/
You think you just let them say that?
Well, if it was up to me, we wouldn't be in this situation
where two sides hate each other this much—I get it, but then here we find ourselves.
Whether or not it's Parler,
it's Twitter, it's Facebook, it's Google,
it's Telegram, WhatsApp, whatever it might be,
you can't stop people and change their opinions by force,
by censoring them.
They'll just go somewhere else and do it.
A study from social psychologist Richard Rogers
found that a robust network of deplatform figures
has already emerged over the past several years on encrypted apps like Telegram,
the preferred platform for pro-democracy activists
in Hong Kong, trying to avoid Chinese censorship.
A transition to a new, more decentralized and private web
may be accelerating as privacy centric DuckDuckGo
has experienced significant growth in search
as a Google alternative.
And the encrypted messaging app Signal saw a big bump
after Elon Musk encouraged the masses to install it.
With a crackdown in progress and likely to intensify,
once a new Congress and president take office,
we should focus instead
on enhancing encrypted communication platforms
that make online speech harder to control
and resisting law enforcement efforts
to weaken vital tools like end to end encryption.
There's a lot that still needs building
to create an alternative digital commons
but it can be accomplished.
Communicating freely might take more work in the future
and your favorite politician might get banned
or your favorite app taken out of the store.
But in this cat and mouse game,
the mice far outnumber of the cats.
That said in the short term,
the decision-makers at Twitter and Facebook
may want to consider that repression tends
to have the unfortunate effect
of pushing legitimate dissidence
and dangerous unsavory extremists into the same channels.
Sigmund Freud theorized that
when thoughts or experiences are repressed,
they inevitably resurface in more deranged and damaging forms.
When our dominant communication platforms,
seek to repress widely held beliefs and opinions,
those beliefs and opinions aren't likely to simply disappear
but rather re-emerge elsewhere in less visible forums,
where they'll face less scrutiny.
The next few years may be ugly
but silencing dissenters will ultimately fail.
Information wants to be free
as Stewart Brand famously quipped,
The great repression will almost certainly
have unintended consequences,
but it can't last forever.